Speaker 1: So as we continue to wait for and
wonder, is Republican Congressman Matt Gates
going to be charged for possibly child sex
trafficking and or other crimes?
The investigation is ongoing.
Matt Gates has retained lawyers expert in
defending against sex crimes.
As we wonder about that, his behavior continues
to become more and more outrageous.
And over the weekend, Matt Gates, actually,
I guess you could call it joking.
I'm not really sure Matt Gates joked about
blowing up capital metal detectors with explosives.
This, of course, relates to the metal detectors
that were installed at the Capitol, at least
in part because it was believed that some
Republican members of Congress, including
Lauren Boebert, maybe others Madison Cawthorn
has talked about being being armed, being
protected, bringing weapons onto the House
floor.
So we're going to go through this piece by
piece media article says.
While campaigning for a Republican congressional
candidate in Central Florida on Saturday,
Congressman Matt Gaetz complained about the
metal detectors in the Capitol.
Lying about why they were installed and going
so far as to joke about blowing them up with
explosives.
The former, the Florida congressman, was in
Lake County to campaign for Florida State
Rep. Anthony Sabatini Sabatini, who is running
for Congress in 2022 and share his Gates's
support for former President Donald Trump.
Gates mentioned Congresswoman Lauren Boebert
objection to the metal detectors that were
installed in the Capitol complex shortly after
the Trump riots.
Multiple Republican lawmakers loudly complained
about the metal detectors, claiming they were
a violation of their constitutional rights.
They weren't.
And Boebert was among those who attempted
to circumvent the screening by walking around
the metal detectors or refusing to allow her
bag to be searched.
All right, so let's take a look at the first
clip here.
Here is Matt Gates talking about blowing up
the metal detectors in the house with either
Tanner Wright or C-4 explosive.
Speaker 4: My friend Lauren Boebert from Colorado.
She seat they put in metal detectors on the
floor of the House because it's like a five
foot nothing woman.
She carries a firearm for her personal protection.
So, oh, they got triggered by that.
I said, Man, is it?
Is it 10:00 Tanzanite or C four?
We want to put in those metal detectors and
we blow them
Speaker 2: up and we take them home.
Yeah.
Speaker 1: Now, in all seriousness, this is
the exact type of thing that causes stochastic
violence, if not stochastic terror.
Aside from whether it's even appropriate,
absent any real world implications for a sitting
member of Congress to be joking about, or
maybe not joking, talking about blowing up
the chamber in which he works and votes, and
in which legislative duties are carried out.
Whether you can say that's fine or it's not
fine or whatever.
If you have an understanding, if you recognize
and realize the degree to which disproportionately
the types of people that follow someone like
Matt Gaetz are folks who would be willing
to do violence in real life to solve political
issues, you start to realize this could actually
encourage someone to go and to try to set
off a bomb at the house.
Now, would they get into where the metal detectors
aren't?
Maybe not.
But that's not really a defense.
This is we've talked about stochastic terror
given a large enough audience.
If you hammer on and hammer on and hammer
on an idea and radicalize people against a
person or institution.
It starts to become statistically likely that
someone it wouldn't be predictable exactly
who.
But that quote sorry for hitting my mike,
that someone is going to go out and actually
act on that now.
As a reminder, we recently had more context
to this.
Lauren Boebert was recently interviewed by
cultural critic and arbiter of ideas.
Dave Rubin and Lauren Boebert sort of smiled
and laughed and kind of took credit, supposedly
for the metal detectors even being there.
Remember this from last week?
Speaker 5: Nancy Pelosi has called me the
enemy within.
We have metal detectors outside of the House
chambers because of me, and it is so, so it
seemed so.
Speaker 1: They now are ridiculing what our
actions that had to be taken because members
of Congress posed a risk in terms of the weapons
they were trying to bring in, as I said last
week.
It's not something to be proud about that
your place of work had to put in metal detectors
because of your actions.
It's not something that I would be humiliated
if that were the case.
Also, from the same very strange appearance
here, Matt Gates says he thinks Democrats
are going to see how many Republican votes
are there and then they will illegally create
Democratic votes to counter that sort of like
as a one to one thing, completely baseless.
No evidence of this.
Take a look at Gates's suggestion.
Speaker 4: I really think.
They like in Fulton County, Georgia.
I think they wait and they see how many votes
the Republicans got in the other parts of
the state, and then that's how many they need
like will into existence.
Speaker 1: So that's a completely un falsifiable
claim.
You can always look at election results and
say, Oh, Democrats won by a thousand Democrats
actually really lost by a thousand, but they
checked how many Republican votes they were.
And then they created 2000 Democratic votes
to take a thousand vote lead completely on
falsifiable hasn't happened.
No evidence that it's happened.
No evidence that Democrats have attempted
it.
Just more poisoning the well, that type of
thing only works on ignorant voters.
There is no evidence that that's done.
And it would be completely on falsifiable.
Just look, you can look at any election result
and in fact, they're doing it.
Mike Pillow does it and these people do it.
They say, No, no, no, no, no.
Trump really won Wisconsin by 200000.
Really?
Where's the evidence?
Well, they won't give us the evidence.
Oh, OK.
Well, then, so how will we?
This is he really won.
You can't falsify a lot of these things, and
that's what makes them great fodder for low
information voters.